moving to our coronavirus coverage  tonight we continue to keep an eye on  climbing covet cases here locally and  across the country  this is more people wait to get  vaccinated let's take a look at the  latest numbers today  nevada is reporting 17 new deaths along  with more than 2 200 new cases  this brings the total to more than 248  thousand  the state's positivity rate is also from  yes up from yesterday rather to  21 percent in clark county more than  1800 new cases were added more than  seven people have died over 2600 people  have lost their lives in total  and more than 189 thousand cases have  been reported  our recovery rate is at 87.3 percent  down from yesterday